JOHN RICH BAR IS THROUGH THE
WINDOW.
SO WHAT DID WE MISS WHILE WE
WERE GONE?
WELL, SEVERAL OF NOXIOUS
LEFT-WING ACTIVISTS,
KYRSTEN SINEMA, FROM A CLASSROOM
AT ARIZONA STATE, TO THE
RESTROOM AND HARASSED HER
OUTSIDE INSTALL.
I'LL ADMIT I'VE DONE THIS MYSELF
WHILE DRUNK, BUT IT HAD NOTHING
TO DO WITH POLITICS.
AND EVERYTHING TO DO WITH A
MISSING BAG OF WEED THAT
JULIE BANDERAS STILL OWES ME.
BUT INSTEAD OF GIVING ME
SENATOR SOME PRIVACY, THEY JUST
CONTINUED THEIR BUSINESS WHILE
SHE DID HERS.
>> WE WANT TO TALK TO YOU REAL
QUICK.
>> ACTUALLY I'M HEADING OUT.
>> RIGHT NOW IS A REAL MOMENT
THAT OUR PEOPLE NEED IN ORDER TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT'S REALLY
HAPPENING.
WE NEED A BUILD BACK BETTER PLAN
RIGHT NOW.
>> Greg: THAT WILL WIN
CONVERTS TO YOUR SIDE.
SHE'S ALWAYS -- IT'S OH IS BEEN
A PARTY SCHOOL, BUT NOW IT'S A
POTTY SCHOOL.
I'M IMPRESSED BY THE SENATOR, IF
SOMEONE EVER RECORDED ME IN THE
BATHROOM STALL THE AUDIO WOULD
SOUND LIKE A MILES DAVIS SOLO.
SO WHY WERE THESE ACTIVISTS SO
OUTRAGED?
THEY CLAIM IT'S BECAUSE SHE
WASN'T SUPPORTING JOE'S BUILD
BACK BETTER AGENDA, BUT WE KNOW
THAT'S B.S., THEY DON'T EVEN
READ IT, THEY DON'T CARE.
BUT THEY CHASED HER INTO THE
STALL ASSUMING THAT SHE'S A GIRL
AND WON'T FIGHT BACK.
BUT KYRSTEN, IF YOU ARE
LISTENING, WE WILL TAKE YOU OVER
MITT ROMNEY ANY DAY.
YOU KNOW HOW TO MAKE THE TOUGH
CHOICES AND YOU LOOK BETTER IN
THIGH-HIGH BUTTES
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: HERE'S WHAT THE
PRESIDENT HAD TO SAY.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, TALKED ABOUT
HOW YOU HAVE 48 DEMOCRATIC VOTES
RIGHT NOW.
THE OTHER TWO HAVE BEEN
PRESSURED OVER THE WEEKEND BY
ACTIVISTS.
JOE MANCHIN HAD PEOPLE SHOW UP
TO
IT'S PART OF THE PROCESS.
>> Greg: WHAT DID HE JUST SAY?
SOMETIMES I THINK HE'S JUST
PLAYING SCRABBLE WITH US IN HIS
HEAD.
BUT THIS KIND OF INVASIVE
HARASSMENT IS THE TYPE OF
DISCOURSE THE LEFT CHAMPIONS,
FROM HARASSING DINERS TO LOOTING
BUSINESSES, IT'S ALL PART OF THE
SAME STRATEGY AND IT'S NO
COINCIDENCE THEY DO SOME OF
THEIR BEST WORK IN THE TOILET.
THEY DON'T GIVE A CRAP EVEN IF
YOU'RE GIVING A CRAP.
EVEN WORSE, THEY REFUSED TO
SPARE A SQUARE.
IF SOMEONE FOLLOWED ME INTO THE
BATHROOM HOLDING A CAMERA PHONE
I THINK IT WOULDN'T END WELL.
♪ ♪
>> COMPLEMENTS OF THE HOOD.
>> Greg: YES.
FIRST OF ALL, WHO FOLLOWS YOU
INTO A BATHROOM FILMING YOU?
WHY CAN'T THEY DO IT THE RIGHT
WAY AND HIDE THE CAMERA?
IT'S COMPLETELY INAPPROPRIATE
AND WHY I ALWAYS BRING MY
SKETCHING PAD.
BUT MOST PEOPLE WOULD CLOBBER
THAT CREEP, ESPECIALLY IF YOU
ARE WITH A KID AT THE TIME.
I ASSUME THE MEDIA WOULD CARE
ABOUT THIS INVASION OF PRIVACY
BUT THEY ALWAYS SIDE WITH THE
PROTESTERS.
THAT'S WHY THEIR RATINGS ARE
HEADING INTO THE TOILET AS WELL.
I WONDER WHERE THIS COULD LEAD.
>> DAVID OF THE CHEST NEWS
NETWORK, WE ARE COVERING THE
KYRSTEN SINEMA STORY HERE AT
ARIZONA STATE UNIVERSITY.
ARE YOU KYRSTEN SINEMA?
>> NO I'M NOT, THIS IS A
BATHROOM, CAN I GET SOME
PRIVACY?
>> THERE'S NO PRIVACY HERE AT
ARIZONA STATE UNIVERSITY.
YOUR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
ARIZONA.
ARIZONA STATE UNIVERSITY IS NOW
IDENTIFYING AS THE UNIVERSITY OF
ARIZONA.
YOU HEARD IT HERE FIRST, BACK TO
YOU.
IF [SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: WE SAW THIS COMING.
REMEMBER EVERYONE IS POLITICALLY
DEPUTIZED BY THE DEMOCRATS NOW.
GET INTO YOUR FACE.
SCIENCE DOESN'T EVEN MATTER, OR
IN THIS CASE BIOLOGY.
LAST WEEK WE TOLD TO THE CDC HAS
GOTTEN RID OF THE TERM "WOMAN"
WHEN DISCUSSING PREGNANCY.
THAT'S BOTH SEXIST AND
MISOGYNIST AND BOY HAVE THE
BROAD'S BEEN COMPLAINING.
[SCATTERED LAUGHTER]
"THE WASHINGTON POST" JOINED IN
SAYING THAT REPORTERS WILL NOW
BE EXPECTED TO WRITE PREGNANT
INDIVIDUALS, BECAUSE NOT ALL
PREGNANT PEOPLE ARE WOMEN.
THE COMPLETE PHRASE "PREGNANT
WOMEN AND OTHER PREGNANT
INDIVIDUALS," MEANING, I
SUPPOSE, MAN.
BUT ONCE AGAIN, A REMINDER TO
ALL YOU NARROW-MINDED TYPES,
YES, MEN CAN GET PREGNANT.
I REFER TO THE MEN WHO HAVE
OVARIES AND WOMBS AND CAN
FERTILIZE AN EGG AND BRING A
BABY TO TERM -- OH WAIT, MEN
DON'T HAVE THAT STUFF.
GOOD LUCK TRYING.
IT YOU PUT A MERCEDES ENGINE IN
THE TOYOTA, IT'S STILL A TOYOTA.
BUT MENTION THE SCIENCE, YOU
RISK MARGINALIZING SOMEONE.
WHO WOULD THAT BE?
GOOD QUESTION.
I HATE TO TELL YOU, BUT WHO IS
GETTING MARGINALIZED IS WOMEN.
MEN NOW APPEAR -- IT'S HAPPENED
BEFORE, BUT THIS IS DIFFERENT.
CHECK THIS OUT, HALF NAKED DUDE
ON THE COVER.
HUGH HEFNER AND THREE DEAD
CHICKS MUST BE TURNING IN HIS
GRAVE.
>> [LAUGHS]
>> Greg: THE ONLY WAY YOU CAN
GET A JOKE OUT OF THREE DEAD
CHICKS IS THAT JOKE.
>> HUGH HEFNER.
>> Greg: I HOPE HE GETS A LOT
OF EXPOSURE FOR THIS, BUT BE
CAREFUL, YOUNG MAN, YOU DON'T
WANT TO GET PREGNANT.
HE'S A SOCIAL MEDIA INFLUENCER
APPARENTLY.
HE'S INFLUENCED ME TO ORDER MY
OWN PAIR OF THOSE SHOES.
SO TIRED OF BORROWING DANA'S.
BUT I GET IT, PLAYBOY IS A DEAD
BRAND AND THE ONLY WAY TO
BREATHE IT BACK TO LIFE IS GOING
WOKE, HOPING TO GET ATTENTION
FROM THE TWITTER MOBS.
AND BECAUSE IT'S A SLOW NEWS DAY
WE ATE IT RIGHT UP.
IT WAS BETWEEN THAT AND A STORY
ABOUT BIDEN PUTTING HIS SHOES IN
THE MICROWAVE BY ACCIDENT.
OR WAS IT BY ACCIDENT?
WE DON'T KNOW.
THE FACT IS ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT ONE THING IN COMMON.
VAPID STUPIDITY.
THE ACTIVISTS WHO CHASE PEOPLE
INTO BATHROOMS ARE STUPID AND
VAPID, THE PEOPLE WHO DEMAND YOU
SAY "PREGNANT AND IF IT'S" ARE
STUPID AND VAPID AND ANYONE WHO
TOOK OVER "PLAYBOY" MAGAZINE,
STUPID, STUPID, AND VAPID.
THEY DECIDED TO LIVE IN A
NONSENSE WORLD AND DRAG THE REST
OF US INTO IT.
ALL OF THE STUPIDITY MAKES ME
MISS NASHVILLE, FOR IT HAS A
DOME OF IMPENETRABLE COMMON
SENSE THAT PROTECTS IT FROM SUCH
IDIOCY.
AND WE NEED TO EXPAND THAT DOME,
OR AT LEAST MOVE UNDER IT.
SURE I HAVE GRITS IN MY PANTS
AND GRAVY IN MY NAVEL, BUT IT
WAS WORTH IT.
NOW I'M BACK AND IT'S GOOD TO
SEE NOTHING'S CHANGED AND AS A
MENTOR NEEDS TO BATHROOM, I
COULDN'T BE HAPPIER.
I FEEL MY WATER BREAKING, OR
MAYBE I JUST NEED TO PEE.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
HE'S A NEW YORK REPUBLICAN,
MEANING HE'S THE ONLY NEW YORK
REPUBLICAN, CONGRESSMAN AND
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATE
LEE ZELDIN!
THERE YOU GO.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
SHE IS SO SOUTHERN SHE USES
MOONSHINE AS MOUTHWASH.
FOX BUSINESS ANCHORED
DAGEN McDOWELL!
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
SHE IS SUCH A DIVA, SHE WILL GET
THE PERSON WHO WROTE THIS FIRED,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
HE'S SO STRONG, EVEN MONDAY
WON'T MESS WITH HIM, MY MASSIVE
SIDEKICK AND THE NWA'S WORLD
HEAVYWEIGHT CHAMPION, TYRUS!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
ALL RIGHT, DAGEN, I AM A LITTLE
BIT RELUCTANT TO ASK YOU WHAT
YOU WOULD DO BUT I ASSUME -- I
ARTY KNOW WHAT YOU WOULD DO BUT
LET'S SAY SOMEBODY FOLLOWED YOU
INTO A BATHROOM WITH A CAMERA
PHONE.
IT'S NOT WHAT THEY BE KILLED,
IT'S HOW QUICKLY WOULD THEY BE
KILLED.
>> I'M A LESSON-TEACHER.
I LIKE PEOPLE WHO COME FOR ME, I
LIKE TO TEACH THEM LESSONS.
I ALSO HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAKE
EVEN ANDY CUOMO UNCOMFORTABLE OR
HARVEY WEINSTEIN, SUMMARY LIKE
THAT.
SO IF YOU FOLLOW ME INTO THE
BATHROOM, WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
LITTLE CHITCHAT WHILE I POP A
SQUAT, AND I'M LEAVING THE STALL
DOOR WIDE OPEN.
AND I'M GOING TO FILM IT AND I'M
GOING TO SIT THERE AND GO "CAN
YOU GO GET ME SOME TP, I RAN
OUT," "DO YOU HAVE ANY
TIC TAC'S?
BECAUSE MY BREATH IS A VERY."
I'M GOING TO ENSURE THAT NOBODY
EVER FOLLOWS ANYBODY INTO A
BATHROOM AGAIN.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY SHE WAS
GOING TO BLESS THEIR HEART, BUT
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH THE SAME
THING.
I DON'T KNOW WHY WE ARE CALLING
THESE PEOPLE ACTIVISTS.
WE NEED TO STOP GETTING THESE
TITLES TO THESE MORONS.
IF THEY FOLLOWED WOMAN INTO THE
BATHROOM.
THAT'S HARASSMENT!
THEY ARE HARASSERS.
THERE'S NOTHING POLITICAL THERE.
THEY'RE NOT DOING ANY FAVORS.
THERE WAS NOTHING THAT THEY
ASKED HER THAT COULDN'T WAIT FOR
HER TO COME OUT OF THE BATHROOM.
THEY TRIED TO INTIMIDATE A WOMAN
IN THE BATHROOM.
THE LAST TIME I CHECKED, THAT IS
A BIG CRIME, TO FOLLOW SOMEONE
INTO THE BATHROOM, RECORDING
THEM WITHOUT PERMISSION AND
BASICALLY THREATENING THEIR JOB
IN THE MOST IGNORANT -- HE
STOPPED BECAUSE HE SENT THE
HIT MAN IN, BUT THE ONE WHO GETS
GENIUS OF THE DAY WAS THE ONE
WHO TOOK LITERALLY 12 SENTENCES
TO SAY WE KNOCKED ON DOORS.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN A POLITICAL
DEBATE GOING "WE HAVE 1.5
KNOCKED ON DOORS OPPOSED TO THE
OTHER TEAM'S ABOUT SO WE ARE
IN."
THEY ARE IDIOTS, BUT THEY
BELIEVE THEY ARE SO POWERFUL
BECAUSE THEY WERE GOING TO TWEET
THIS OUT.
THEY THINK THEIR HEROES BECAUSE
WE CALL THEM THINGS LIKE
INFLUENCERS, ACTIVISTS.
IF THIS HAS NEVER BEEN A SAFER
TIME IN THIS COUNTRY TO BE AN
ACTIVIST, BECAUSE WHY?
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION.
SO YEAH, THEY ARE REAL BRAVE
ATTACKING THEM AND THEY ARE
BEING PUT UP AS LIKE THEY WERE
DOING SOMETHING SPECIAL.
THEY ARE HARASSERS AND WE NEED
TO START CALLING THEM THAT.
>> Greg: DOES THIS HAPPEN TO
YOU?
THE WORD THING ABOUT THIS,
CONGRESSMAN, IS THAT WE HAVE OF
NOXIOUS PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT, BUT
WE DON'T DO THIS STUFF.
IT'S ONLY DIRECTED -- BECAUSE
THEY BELIEVE THAT THEIR HEARTS
AND MORALITY IS IN THE RIGHT
PLACE.
IF YOU ARE A NONLIBERAL, THEN
YOU ARE SOMEHOW EVIL AND THAT
EXCUSES ANY BEHAVIOR, ALTHOUGH I
DON'T THINK THEY THOUGHT THAT
FAR IN ADVANCE.
I DO THINK THESE ARE MORONS.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS?
>> THIS HAPPENED TO ME EARLIER
TODAY.
NOT FOLLOWING MINTO RESTAURANT,
I'M JUST TRYING TO GO TO MY
OFFICE AND THEY'RE ALL WAITING
OUTSIDE TO CREATE A MOMENT TO GO
VIRAL.
THEY WERE WAITING OUTSIDE OF THE
FRONT DOOR OF OUR BUILDING HERE
INSIDE THE CITY.
THE OTHER EXTREME OF THIS IS
WHEN -- WE HAD COLLEAGUES IN THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES A FEW
YEARS AGO WHERE STEVE SCALISE
ALMOST LOST HIS LIFE.
SOME OF THESE PEOPLE, THEY
FOLLOW THEIR LEADERS, THE MAXINE
WATERS WHO ASKS FOR
CONFRONTATION.
THEY TAKE IT TO THE NEST LEVEL
AND THANK GOD FOR THE CAPITOL
POLICE.
HE SAVED A WHOLE OF PEOPLE'S
LIVES.
OBVIOUSLY THE TACTIC IS WRONG.
IF I AM SINEMA, I DON'T THINK
THIS HELPS CONVINCE ME TO VOTE
FOR THEIR SEVERAL TRILLION
DOLLAR MONSTROSITY OF A BILL.
I THINK THIS WOULD ACTUALLY MAKE
ME LESS LIKELY TO VOTE FOR THE
BILL, BUT I WOULD SAY THAT AS
FAR AS SINEMA GOES, REGARDLESS,
SHE DID MAKE THE BEST OF WHAT
WAS A [BLEEP] SITUATION.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: YOU'VE GOT MY VOTE
FOR GOVERNOR FOR JUST SAYING
[BLEEP].
KAT, THERE IS AN INTERESTING
THING ABOUT HOW THERE IS A
DISTORTED OUTSIDE VIEW OF THEIR
POWER BECAUSE OF THEIR ONLINE
PRESENCE, AND YOU HAVE A GUY WHO
PORTRAYED HIMSELF AS A MODERATE
NOW JUST GOING WOKE BECAUSE HE
THINKS THAT THESE PEOPLE --
THEIR OPINIONS MATTER MORE AND
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION.
>> YEAH, IT WAS INTERESTING TO
ME THAT THERE WAS NO EVEN
HESITATION TO FOLLOW HER IN
THERE, AND IT WASN'T JUST HER IN
THERE.
LIKE THERE'S PEOPLE COMING IN
AND OUT OF THE OTHER STALLS.
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE!
>> HOW ARE THOSE PEOPLE DOING?
>> AND FLUSHING!
>> AND FLUSHING.
NOBODY SEES THAT AND THINKS
THAT'S OKAY.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO SEE THAT
AND SAY IT'S OKAY BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THE SAME PROBLEM AS THOSE
PEOPLE DO, THEY ARE IN THEIR
LITTLE BUBBLE AND THEY THINK
THAT THEY'RE DOING THE RIGHT
THING, BUT IF YOU ARE FOLLOWING
SOMEONE INTO THE BATHROOM,
YOU'VE ALWAYS GONE TOO FAR.
>> Greg: YES, THAT IS TRUE, NO
MATTER WHAT BATHROOM IT IS.
IT DOESN'T EVEN HAVE TO BE A
GENDERED BATHROOM.
CAN YOU BEAT SOMEBODY UP IN THE
BATHROOM?
>> YES.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
>> YOU CAN BEAT SOMEBODY UP
ANYWHERE.
>> Greg: IF THE POLICE COME,
CANNOT -- IT IS AGAINST THE LAW
TO FILM SOMEONE IN THE BATHROOM.
LET'S FIND OUT THAT'S MY WIFE
AND THERE AND THERE WAS A GUY IN
THERE, I CAN CLOBBER HIM, RIGHT?
>> THERE'S A LOT TO WORK WITH
TOO.
THE PORCELAIN IS VERY HARD.
>> USUALLY ONE SHOT YOU SET THEM
ON THE TOILET AND NOBODY WILL
BOTHER THEM AND THEN YOU CLOSE
THE DOOR AND WALK AWAY AND YOU
GO LET'S GO, SNOOP